[Musique]
nous sommes à cramator ce qui a une
vingtaine de kilomètres de la ligne de
front une ville encore épargnée mais
très convoité elle aussi par les Russes
la moitié des résidents sont déjà partis
vladyslave Arseni lui est resté sa vie a
basculé il y a un an
cet entrepreneur en construction
s'occupe maintenant d'évacuer les plus
vulnérables
c'est important dit-il chaque citoyen
veut faire sa part et aider l'Ukraine
dans ce conflit la journée sera chargée
avec Vlad un autre bénévole il doit
aller chercher cette personne
on arrive au petit village de
constantinivica pas de tir tout est
calme
mais le minibus a du mal à avancer les
Russes sont très glacées
ils réussissent finalement à se frayer
un chemin
le premier passager marche péniblement
Sergueï volo à 70 ans il est amputé
d'une jambe en raison de la gangrène
sa famille préférait qu'il parte loin du
front dans un lieu sécuritaire
on ne voulait pas faire ça mais on n'a
pas le choix à nous dire
Sergueï pardon seul un peu confus avec
dans ce sac tout ce qu'il apporte avec
lui le véhicule repart mais cette fois
la rue est bloquée il y a un accident il
devra faire un détour
nous filons maintenant vers cramatorze
trop dangereux nous explique vladyslave
et qui ne soit plus capable de s'occuper
d'eux-mêmes sous les bombardements
ici c'est toute une famille qui part
deux enfants la mère le père il se
dépêche
trop anxieuse elle n'en dit pas plus la
journée avance c'est le dernier arrêt et
le plus délicat
c'est une femme de 71 ans qui deviennent
chercher elle est immobilisée et ne peut
plus rester dans sa maison ASA Alexandre
ovnin est installé à l'arrière sur une
couverture
c'est ça qui est un dernier au revoir
tout se fait très vite
ladislave emmène maintenant ces
passagers à la gare de potrovsk à une
heure de là
sur le quai c'est d'abord hazalexandre
rovna que l'on fera embarquer elle sera
prise en charge par d'autres bénévoles à
l'intérieur du train jusqu'à ni pro plus
à l'ouest les autres évacués attendent
leur tour soulagés de quitter cette zone
de guerre
il y avait beaucoup de bombardements de
Rocket dit-il
sa femme ajoute qu'ils ont eu très peur
et qu'ils ne veulent qu'une chose la
paix partout il s'engouffre ensuite dans
le train première étape avant de partir
pour l'étranger
vladyslave envoie partir un peu plus
chaque jour
se calment réalisent maintenant que plus
le temps passe et plus ce sera difficile
au contraire
c'est l'heure du départ un train vers
l'inconnu et pour beaucoup l'espoir de
revenir quand la guerre sera finie
Céline Galipeau Radio-Canada kramatorze